there's been a lot of bombing left right
and above um
everywhere
it would be a lie to say that i'm not
afraid because this is a one-way ticket
i know i'm going there for a good reason
and if i don't see my family my friends
and the people i love here on this earth
again i have faith that i will meet them
after death
[Music]
in ukraine it's not just ukrainians who
are fighting
thousands of people from abroad have
joined the battle
who are they
and why are they doing it
if i'm needed to help my comrades at the
front line i'll go there if i'm needed
to take care of civilians i'll do that
whatever job the legion gives me i'll do
it
as he calls himself is from latin
america
for security reasons we don't disclose
his exact location
he's preparing to leave his home
kapon tells me he works as a paramedic
he seems to have plenty of friends
overall his life seems pretty normal to
me
he's one of several people i get in
touch with on social media
here people who want to join the
ukrainian army connect from around the
globe
quite a few people who say they are
already there post about it but a lot of
what they post is hard to verify
in our first online encounter capon
doesn't reveal his identity yet
he wants to join the army as a combat
medic
i saw these terrible images of how they
attacked civilian zones with missiles
people dying in their apartments and
attacks against humanitarian corridors
i saw so many terrible images of
suffering civilians including children
and it broke my heart to see them
and as a paramedic i have the skills to
help them i know i have something to
offer
the 19 year old tells me he still lives
with his parents
he prefers not to share pictures of his
family though
they don't agree with what i'm doing the
day before yesterday my grandmother was
crying
they're afraid and i understand
i'm not going on a holiday i'm going to
a country at war and will risk my life
to help other people
he says his father even offered him
money to stay
but a few days later it's time to leave
his friends throw a farewell party
[Music]
he sends me videos from his journey
it's the first time that he's going
abroad
he doesn't come from a rich family the
mother of a friend chips in to pay for
the flight
in return he has to promise to come back
alive
[Music]
sandra from norway has already joined
the ukrainian army
they refer me to her
the life she depicts on social media is
not for the faint of heart
[Music]
she used to be a fisher
then served as a representative for her
ethnic group the sami people
she tells me that after that she trained
as a combat medic
now she says she's on the front lines
first of all is the moral obligation
uh this is home base it's in europe uh
um we owe them so
if you can't help you should
she tells me what her days are like you
can't really prepare because you don't
know what's gonna happen there might be
an airstrike and it might be artillery
and might be relocating
um
so you just have to run by it day by day
on her social media account she poses
with weapons
[Music]
she tells me she has no qualms about
using her gun
well it is what it is it's your job it's
what you have to do so
it's the one who's who fires first
that's how it goes we're not the
attackers we are the defenders we are
not the one crossing any borders they
did
capone flies to krakow in poland close
to the ukrainian border
temperatures in eastern europe just have
dipped to near freezing a climate that
kapon has never experienced before
i join him for the next lag of his
journey
the first stop a military shop
he still needs a bulletproof vest since
he isn't sure whether the army provides
one you have a
body armor
no but another is the
body armor
you have
five five pound eleven
the military shops in krakow are overrun
right now
what are you going to do
well apparently it's difficult to find
body armor in krakow so i have to go
without and hope that i don't get shot
at
this part
isn't that a suicide mission
it would be good to have one but even
with a vest the bullets come through so
the only thing i can do is hope to come
back in one piece
by chance capone meets other men who
also want to join the battle
oh we go today
today all right
medic
yes paramedic to me he makes a dubious
impression
the man doesn't want to be filmed but
claims he fought in iraq and afghanistan
working for a private military
contractor
kapon has no combat experience so he
decides to train on a shooting range
he's now joined by a man from colombia
who goes by tattle
they met online in a group of
spanish-speaking volunteers
they also test an ak-47 which is used in
ukraine
the training at the shooting range is
intended for civilians and is supposed
to be just for fun
it's just the second time that kapon has
ever held a gun he tells me
after half an hour he is done
it doesn't prepare me for war as such
but at least i know how to handle a
weapon correctly that i might use in
ukraine
for people like kapon the international
legion is their main port of call in
ukraine
on instagram it advertises itself as an
adventurous heroic group of comrades
it was founded just days after the war
started and is believed to have around
20 000 members i've come here to fight
fight the russians and defend
democracy and freedom
according to the legion they are paid
the equivalent of ukrainian soldiers of
their rank
sometimes less than 500 euros a month
their contract lasts until the war is
over
their spokesperson tells me that people
who want to join have to pass several
tests in ukraine
as a rule they are sent to some of the
hottest
spots
on the front line and are taking care in
some
very
let's say delicate uh offensive and
defensive operation can you prove that
you don't use them as cannon fodder
well i think it's very difficult for
anyone to prove anything
in this war what i can say is that
we can give all public and private
assurances
that no one in the army is interested in
sending people to the front who are not
ready
the russian government sees the
international fighters as mercenaries
which could result in worse treatment if
they are captured
i ask an expert for his take on it
they are not mercenaries it's not a
company it's not a commercial entity
which is sending those fighters there
there is quite a difference
and as long as they are integrated into
the
forces of the host country they are not
mercenaries is this phenomena of
international fighters that we see right
now in ukraine is this something new or
has this always been present also during
other kinds of conflicts
well it's not new of course we've seen
this in in in afghanistan in iraq and
other middle eastern countries
but um to make the distinction clear
when those
islamist fighters joined an insurgency
it's completely different from joining
the ranks of
an existing country
joining the forces the legal legitimate
government forces
in poland i meet a german fighter who
tells me he has been in ukraine for two
weeks
[Music]
poland seems to be a jumping off point
for foreign volunteers
in total i talk to seven of them on and
offline
much of what they say is hard to verify
some of the men don't appear credible
their mental or social conditions appear
unstable
a man from estonia who claims he's at
the front suddenly ends our contact
which worries me i'm not sure what
happened to
[Music]
him i joined kapon and tattoo on their
way to the border
the international legion officially only
accepts people with live combat
experience
but they give it a try anyway
tatu at least served for eight years in
the colombian military he says
recently he was working in spain but
lost his job
for him the war is also a career
opportunity
why am i taking this risk
i often ask myself that and don't have
an answer
i think it's also the excitement the
adrenaline it's a chance to prove myself
i think about it constantly and feel
nervous i'd be lying if i said i wasn't
afraid
but with this fear comes adrenaline
[Music]
time for the last voice messages
i want you to know that everything's
okay
i love you
i'll send you a message when i can
yo
after death i think god will judge us
for what we did in life whether it was
good or bad
i'm grateful to my family that they
introduced me to catholicism
my faith gives me hope and it keeps me
safe
i know that i'm going there for a good
reason
and if i don't see my family and my
friends and the people i love here on
this earth again
i hope i will meet them after death
[Music]
the man who sits next to them is from
ukraine
that's your family yes my family
they're still in ukraine he's going to
the border to get his mother and bring
her to safety
his brother and cousin are at the front
he tells me
so what does he think of the foreign
fighters
is do a good job
for the peace in the world and peace in
ukraine
because we cannot stop this war
ourself
we need to help
to the border is from her
most people are going the opposite
direction
more than 5 million ukrainians have left
their country so far
i'm really cold and a bit nervous now
that i see the people here the
volunteers the soldiers the families
crossing the border i'm even more
motivated and excited than i was before
does he really think he can change
anything
i'm not rambo nothing special
but each grain of sand helps
and if i just save the life of a few
fighters or people who need me i'll have
made a difference
they want to join the legion the next
day
my journey with them ends here
but they promise to stay in touch
[Music]
i head back to germany
i'm still in contact with several people
on their way to the international legion
some of them turn around the last minute
and i received sad news
the man from estonia who said he was at
the front and then stopped communicating
with me
is no longer alive
his brother tells me he returned home
but then killed himself
[Music]
he appeared to be mentally unstable
shortly before his suicide he apparently
watched video clips of the war
[Music]
sandra who's been at the front for quite
some time
is still there and determined to stay
ah yes there's been a lot of bombing
left right and above um
everywhere um
so you get used to that too uh the human
brain is is wired
to just um
get used to whatever situation you have
to get used to uh and i know that sounds
weird but
uh you can get used to anything
including bombing when do you think will
you be back home
i will be back when this war is over
when there's no more need for me here
then i will go home
kapon seems to have a bit of a roller
coaster ride
the international legion at first
rejects him and several others
but ten days later he tells me the
legion suddenly did accept him
he writes i'm happy and sends me a
picture of the body armor he was given
on instagram he posts you are the only
one who can make all of your dreams come
true
besides paramedic tasks he tells me he
is now also receiving regular combat
training to be able to defend himself
in a few days
he could be sent to the front
we agree that for security reasons this
will be our last interview
they will train me for combat with real
ammunition
everything as if i was a real fighter
have you thought about leaving
you do think about it when you hear
detonations when you're close to
exploding grenades when you hear sirens
and are in the cold for hours wearing
just a sweater
also i haven't showered in a week since
there's no bathroom
so you do start to think
yes i realized it's even worse than what
you see on the news everything is worse
because you're the main target
it's quite ugly
it's a strange feeling to say goodbye
and i hope he will make it back home in
one piece
[Music]
you